what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
on the [ __ ] lord's day checking
in with you guys
youtube patreon twitter
just to let you know what's happening in
the lord's day yeah i know cam
newton's got the [ __ ] covid and the
president's got the covert my heart goes
out to all of them
but we still got to do what we got to do
it's the lord's day
we got to spark up a [ __ ] number here
you know what i'm saying who the [ __ ]
are you
you forget about me you thought i forgot
about you you [ __ ] lunatics i didn't
forget about nobody
i'm moving in trying to get [ __ ]
settled a podcast
is coming not just the one on patreon
uncle joey's joint isn't in full effect
this week
coming your [ __ ] way not to mention
that
i'm also doing a small residency at
uncle vinnie's in point pleasant on
wednesday nights at 8 o'clock
38 tickets that's all there is so if you
don't come
don't feel bad there's no comps there's
no friend ain't nobody it's just 38
people
we're trying not to get covered is that
cool with you what do you think about
that one but
enough is enough i sparked this number
that gave you some time to roll one up
grab a pipe
use your [ __ ] girlfriend's fingers as
a pipe you would do that you [ __ ]
put weed in here anyway that's a long
time ago
give us a [ __ ] let's get down
there's my man cutting trees as usual
they cut a lot of trees here i don't
know why i don't
they cut the trees out to california to
[ __ ] burn them i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on here
but this weed is sensation
what is some leftover cream brulee from
urban trees
on the maven label [ __ ] tremendous
you understand me
but i know a lot of you guys are going
through some hard times
or whatnot [ __ ] it it's covetville we're
going in two hands
hold on oh a little something for the
espiritos
malos i want to have a little breakfast
with the family
now they went to the park so i forgot to
do a little video with you [ __ ]
just as a reminder who the [ __ ] uncle
joey is
just cause it's time in the morning what
i'm a bad guy who gives a [ __ ] i could
be drinking i could be a strip club i
could be snorting though
in my backyard smoking a number
welcoming you
to a new [ __ ] week with a new set of
rules a new set of priorities
and guess who's running things this week
you are [ __ ]
that's it and that's that you're the
boss of your whole [ __ ] thing you're
the ceo
of [ __ ] uh whatever ink that's it
it's up to you it's on you you're having
a rough week go [ __ ] yourself
put the mask on and go straight ahead
don't bother nobody you don't know
nothing you don't want to know nothing
very normal neighborhood people running
people cutting trees people knock on
your door and ask you your child wants
to play
this is what i'm talking about but who
gives a [ __ ]
we're here we're queer we got to see
each other on the lord's day smoke a
little [ __ ] roots
and that's all that matters if you're
not high by [ __ ]
let me tell you something you don't
think i smoked a bone this morning at 8
30 when i woke up are you kidding me
before breakfast just to get the wind
going because you got to get the wind
going if you don't get the wind going
ain't nothing going to happen for you
today
as we say you got to put a little pep in
your [ __ ] step jack
but we're here and that's all that
matters uncle joey's joint is dropping
this week
i don't know what name it's coming in
bare bones so i don't want you to expect
[ __ ] lights camera action
we're doing bad bones until the
equipment comes in
because these [ __ ] you know
everything is two
weeks my chair is not going to come to
october 30th the compressor is not
coming till january you know everything
is on
on [ __ ] uh uh whatever the [ __ ] you
call it the chinese
people are taking a break they're
sending [ __ ] slowly unlike the [ __ ]
rap
[Music]
oh the smell of marijuana in the morning
makes me go [ __ ] bananas you know
what i'm saying
but i just hit you up let you know i'm
back
i'm doing four wednesdays listen don't
expect nothing uh you know don't expect
[ __ ] bill bird to show up
this is joey diaz raw you know
ideas just working [ __ ] out
just uh getting ready for the [ __ ]
next year just like to be prepared man
one night a week ain't gonna kill nobody
gets me out of the house
gives the girls a break we got a full
week this week monday we're going to
dinner tuesday my wife's going to dinner
wednesday i do comedy you know
we're just getting back to normality man
that was very important
i was starting to lose my mind i still
am losing my mind it comes
and it [ __ ] goes but thank god for
you guys
my peeps on patreon you know answering
mail [ __ ] like that
it keeps me [ __ ] saying it's
normality so i want to thank you guys
from the bottom of my heart but what's
with the mushiness joey
sparked that [ __ ] titan you know what
i'm saying when you think about the
titans
19 people got covered what the [ __ ] are
you doing you all [ __ ] the same stripper
what happened look at these numbers
these numbers like four that true tested
built to [ __ ] get you [ __ ]
denominated you know what i'm saying
we should all be at church we should be
good christians but [ __ ] it this is the
best we could do right now
get together with each other i don't
know i got a cookie in the house or
something
if it makes you feel better but [ __ ] it
it's us
[ __ ] and to let you know
it's the beginning of sober october so
either you're in
yeah if you're in you're obviously
watching and you're
obviously sparking so what are you gonna
do
oh my goodness the patreon t
is going to affect on the 12th it's
gonna go to three dollars
five ten and fifteen whatever the [ __ ]
we decide to do
and that's it and that's that we're
working it i'm gonna give you we're
gonna start taping some [ __ ] music
shows this week
we're gonna go for it [ __ ] it low range
as long as you have content that's all
that matters i'm over here [ __ ] three
weeks pounding my head off the wall
trying to do this trying to do that get
this set up and i'm like all these
[ __ ] want his content
they want communication they want the
voice they want they want to
they want to know what's going on it's
an hour out of that day that
that they just get the [ __ ] zone out
and i get it
i did it last night and i enjoyed it i
watched the honeymooners last night i
got nice and [ __ ] stoned i watched
the 9 31
then the 11 and the 11 30 i passed out
somewhere in between that
what are you gonna do
that's it and that's that i was just
here
thinking about you [ __ ] letting
you know uncle joey's joint is in full
effect this week
october 5th okay patreon.com slash joey
diaz that'll always be there
we're raising the ts357935
10 and 15. and you got me
that's it you know i'm with you
[ __ ] i'm with you
you're with me and these [ __ ] want to
be with us but they can't
because they showed their true colors
throughout this whole [ __ ] thing so
now it's down to us
that's it us [ __ ] 14 15
000 on a [ __ ] ship
the rest of them are ratting on one
another you know what the [ __ ]
taking sides who don't know nothing me i
don't give a frenchman as [ __ ] they
can't do dick to me they can't take none
from me and to be honest with you
i have a nun dick remember i'm a
criminal if somebody says i stabbed you
in the neck
believe him that's the kind of [ __ ] i do
somebody says i robbed him
believe him that's the [ __ ] i do but
somebody says i did something to grab
get the [ __ ] out of here i got better
things to do with my time you [ __ ]
filthy [ __ ]
i love it towards the end it's like a
time released [ __ ] joint that's when
the reefer really cultivates
in the joint you get that thc buildup
and you're smoking and you're toking
i'm starting to see three [ __ ]
cameras that's when you know this is a
good [ __ ] time you know what i'm
saying
but that's it and that's that no
politics no religion
straight up love we don't we don't we
don't have time to be [ __ ] arguing
about dumb [ __ ]
this is all about love you know like i
said on the
the shirt for the design for [ __ ] uh
patreon
it's the mind of joey diaz it's it
starts with [ __ ]
fear and anger and hate and
you know confusion and addiction
and then prison and all sudden what
changed it all
comedy and love at the end [ __ ]
took care of everything so love takes
care of addictions whatever you
got you gotta find something to love
even even if it's a [ __ ] gerbil
for an animal like me was a little cat
that saved my [ __ ] life
so for every everybody's got everything
something works
different for everybody for you it might
be standing on your head and spit
nickels
i don't know i ain't no [ __ ] psychic
what i will tell you is
it's a beautiful day to be alive today
and you need to get out there
and make something happen whether it's
sunday monday thursday wednesday and
thursday no more sitting around
govind's been here for seven months what
are you gonna do you gotta work around
it
if you're hiding in the house like a
[ __ ] mazda you know
you you you're wasting your life away
you're killing yourself to live go out
there mingle
build up your immune system a little bit
[ __ ] walk
vitamin d it's sunny today you don't
know after i see you [ __ ] you
don't think i'm gonna go for a little
walk in the sun
get a little vitamin d on this [ __ ]
little bell i feel like
[ __ ] yeah
so take that to the back [ __ ] so
don't forget
i release a mini podcast on patreon
on mondays and wednesdays 20 minutes
little music
you know but now uncle joey's joint is
coming out in full effect
but i'm not waiting until october 18th
we're starting something for you
this week so you have it so keep your
eyes open
don't say uncle joe you didn't tell me i
found that it's gonna be on apple
it's gonna probably be on youtube and
patreon the first couple of weeks until
we really get going
and then we'll blast you but it'll be on
youtube for sure you know what i'm gonna
lead you
i want you to see me i want you to look
my eyes there's no sunglasses on i'm not
trying to be [ __ ] cool
i mean [ __ ] you'll never see
uncle you could never find the picture
with uncle joy with sunglasses just a
headshot at the comedy store i took
with the sunglasses down you know why
because i always want you to see my eyes
and i want to see yours
that's a little secret you never found
out till now i don't wear sunglasses
i don't intend to i don't like them i
don't even like when people wear them i
want to see your eyes [ __ ]
and with that looks like this mule is
dead
me i just want to check in with you on a
beautiful sunday morning
and let you know i'm back [ __ ] in
full effect podcast
uncle vinnie's on wednesday and [ __ ]
slinging dick and back to giving out
bubble gum that's it
the anxiety comes and goes i work with
it i'll be with it that's what we do
we breed we say hell marry and we move
[ __ ] forward now
if you don't mind i gotta finish this
number and i gotta go take
a tremendous [ __ ] you're gonna have to
take a [ __ ] on the lord's day
today's the day one of those [ __ ] two
flushes
today's the day i love you guys with all
my heart
thank you for your support on patreon
thank you for your support on youtube
thank you for your support
all around you guys know my heart is
stay black have a good week
and keep your eyes open for uncle joey's
joint
it's that simple i love you
[ __ ]